the shortest route between Russia and
the United States is over the North Pole
so if the Cold War had ever become hot
the bombs would have been going straight
over here
this is Tuktoyaktuk on the Arctic Ocean
in the Canadian Northwest Territories
and that behind me with the dough's was
once the military's dew line the distant
early warning line or at least part of
it the new line was built in the 1950s
57 radar bases ranging all the way from
the Aleutian Islands to Greenland they
look to the sky around-the-clock and if
any aircraft showed up on radar but
weren't supposed to be there well there
was a chance that those were Soviet
bombers carrying nuclear weapons to
North American targets and the
governments would have somewhere between
an hour and four hours to scramble some
sort of response construction of the dew
line was an enormous operation thousands
and thousands of people had to be
transported to the Arctic provided with
food and housing and the hundreds of
thousands of tons of equipment and
supplies that they need to build the
line but the military is good at
logistics or at least the vast number of
civilian contractors that they hired
were all the bases were completed in
just two and a half years and North
America was prepared for Soviet attack
at the cost of around half a billion
dollars from the two governments there
were other costs to less financial for a
lot of the folks that lived near the dew
line sites the sudden influx of people
and equipment destroyed their way of
life although that is a story that I am
not qualified to tell the construction
also contaminated a lot of the local
environment standards then aren't what
they are now and the cleanup is still
going on and for all that the dew line
lasted about five years until it was
obsolete because shortly after it was
completed both the Soviet Union and the
United States start to put their nuclear
warheads not on aircraft but our
intercontinental ballistic missiles but
didn't need eight or nine hours of
flight over the pole instead the first
wave of attack would come from rockets
that would take half an hour and
literally go over the top of the dew
line half of these stations were shut
down a few years later the rest of the
line including this station here well
they played a role in their defense
after all it if they weren't here the
Soviet Union could have theoretically
still sent bombers over the pole but
they weren't the shield that North
America hoped
they would be US President Eisenhower
and his memoirs said that military
technology will if it works it's
obsolete the dew line kept running
though at least until the 90s when a
more modern system was constructed now
the site is part of a North warning
system part of a modern radar defense
around the whole continent that can
detect basically anything inbound at any
altitude which is why I'm not allowed
near it governments on this side of the
pole want to be sure the Cold War might
be over but just in case they'd better
keep watching
you